how functional or dysfunctional is is
the United basis and what can we do to
to make that institution again that that
that will do its job if you're gonna
talk United Nations we could talk till
next week but but I do think if we think
about institutions in general I think
those who are populating most of the
institutions of powers there is a sense
of complacency and I do think there
needs to be a rethinking about how we
can make sure that some of these
institutions serve people best for
example the European Union was a
creation to help to avoid war and it
wasn't I see it as an as an entity that
was exporting values nowadays it seems
as if the EU is more like it's seen at
least by people as something where it is
trying to avoid the import of either
refugees or or or chaos and and I think
what we need to do is reinvent the
European Union as a place where we're
basically that can protect its citizens
from from the disadvantages of
globalization because there are lots of
advantages but also disadvantages we
need to show that the European Union for
example yes you can have this Paris
sovereign organization but that can
still mean that you can also have have
national nation-states that that play a
role and so it's I think it requires a
rethink of how some of these
institutions work and that each of them
I mean the UN needs to be rethought
but even national institutions need to
be rethought I mean some of the
countries you know I look at the United
Kingdom what's happening there is that
this the social welfare system has was
established in the 50s has not been
rethought since done so it's not
benefiting those who need it most it
needs a complete rethink but it can be
done it's clear that politics have
consequences we've just seen this in the
last few days and then need to reach
across all lines and build bridges is
more urgent than ever before in this
recent American election
Donald Trump did not get more votes than
Mitt Romney four years ago he got about
sixty million votes Hillary Clinton the
end of the day we'll have more popular
votes than Donald Trump by about two
million but she will be about six
million short of what Barack Obama got
in 2012 so there's a missing
participation on the part of people who
should understand especially that their
futures are at stake many of those who
were missing were the Millennials the
younger generation some of them may have
been responding to various stereotypes
and felt themselves disillusioned or
they felt that they didn't need to
participate they had something else to
do that's what happened and brexit they
were the younger generation was largely
for remain and they didn't show up
and so brexit nair only one so it's the
burden really falls on the next
generation to understand that it's
participation for its own future is
absolutely essential and that politics
is not something foreign to them not
something alien but it's very much about
themselves and that it's up to them to
shape it and make it in their own image
to go back to the United Nations and
that you and the World Bank and the IMF
I happen to be in these corridors for
the last 30 35 years of my life of
course again I have to say they have
been doing trying some and they have
some good brains but honestly speaking
it became a dumping place for many old
ministers or wives of old ministers and
first ladies or prime ministers at least
from our region from our region can you
believe it or not that UNDP when Gaddafi
was hanging the Libyan in the in the
streets of Libya UNDP chose his daughter
to be the ambassador of peace so that
tells you how the hypocrisy is in this
United Nation and the first lady's and
the wife of the Prime
at least in our regions are the one who
are getting most of their funding and
most of the support so I think really
the time has come and for you people
that at least you early you know who you
are unfortunate to be honest with you
very fortunate you have you are paying
your taxes for this institution so we
are helpless so it is your voices that
you need to push your representative in
these four organizations to really clean
it it's so much cleaning so much
cleansing and I think it's becoming very
bureaucratic very unfair and very
politicized and again controlled by the
super powers this is it Europe after
World War one after the after the moral
collapse of Europe and we exported our
ideal of to have a political moral power
to America war one world war two and
everything that happened that now we are
in the situation in which I still don't
have any clue what kind of political
power can guide us out of this mess
Steve do you have based on reason or
technology inside this certainly we
should not underestimate the good that
institutions can can do they will not
save the world but they can improve the
world and the United Nations which is a
horribly flawed and corrupt and often
ridiculous organization but it actually
has done some good the mere fact that it
established the international norm that
states may not be conquered that they
may not go out of existence
so Poland for example has continued to
exist since 1945 in many periods of
history it was just carved up no member
of the United Nations has gone out of
existence through conquest and as I
documented it in the book rates of death
in warfare although they are still
horrifying are far lower than than they
used to be lower than they were during
the Vietnam War during the Korean War to
say nothing of
two world wars so we mustn't with all of
the world's problems we must remember
never say it can't get any worse
it can get worse it was worse you stated
that we should not expect too much now
from the world of politics in terms of a
guidance how to I think well I think
what's clear is that there's an
emergence of an authoritarian model
including in the United States that
extends as well to Europe and all the
way to Turkey and that that's a
challenge to democracy I think that
there's a new challenge in the West and
to not only Western coherence and the
West as an alliance on every level but
also to Western ideas and ideals and to
the very concept of the Enlightenment
democracy was was you know for a long
time you know the code word for a better
world not necessarily saving the world
but at least for a better world
democracy what's the status of democracy
in your region of the world democracy
what's going on with the democracy in
the euro particle wrong with democracy
in America it's not a very nice picture
so how to restore democracy now what's
going on with education and how can we
how can we get that kind of education we
are in need of Fareeda
you
Farida no yes yes again
democracy is a package of many
ingredients so democracy prerequisite
for democracy is you know good
leadership capable leadership no
education when when when Rob told me
that I'm coming to this conference I've
been talking to asking many people I
mean I'm going to Amsterdam to talk
about how we can make a better world so
how we can make a better world many
people tell me well you're losing your
time stay home it's so cold and don't go
because it's a joke but I think the
majority the majority were talking about
education many were talking about
freedom many many many were talking
about replacing these leaders how we are
going to have anything since we are
having the actual they are not elected
they are thieves there are dictators
they are ignorant many of them they are
so we are helpless that's what we have
been like I've I talked earlier but
definitely democracy democracy of course
we all of us will be fighting for it and
they think now we are planting the seeds
we will die and we will not live all
these dreams to be honest I'm sure I'm
not going to live my dreams but never
mind my granddaughters and my
grandchildren would love it so now there
is a very vibrant movement in all the
Arab region by women particularly young
women and young men it's unbelievable
what's going on education is not only
education of the intelligence is not
only knowledge as is intended by many
liberalism but is education also of the
of the will in relation to the good
education of ethic education of values
because in the country you have in many
universities they say I know
so someone say that Obama go to his
original university and they you are the
leaders you need to have the power
but don't explain what is the meaning of
the power this is the question if we
don't have education of moral ethics
Aristotle learn about justice in the
politics and about freedom and an abra
friendship in the politics this we need
to have an education of ball because the
human being is good not because have a
great intellect but because have the
will to go to the to the good this is
very important question today if I might
speak to that wise notion of the
spiritual and moral value of democracy
that is central to the very idea of
democracy which is a political ideal
it's a constitutional ideal but it's
also a moral ideal and if I can cite
Lincoln as I would not be a slave so I
would not be a master that is a moral
idea as well
it's a spiritual idea and it is an ideal
of democracy we face it crisis of
democracy within the United States in
which democracy is used against
democracy in which law is used against
the rule of law winch justice is used
against justice a seeming paradox in
which a plutocrat is depicted as a
messianic leader of the masses
you